the world health organization team has
been shuffling on and off buses
whisked around wuhan to investigate the
origins of covet 19.
it looks carefully stage managed with
the press kept at a distance
but one member of the team in his first
interview with a british broadcaster
since arriving in china
insists they are asking tough questions
and making real progress
a lot of people saying well this is
effectively going to be
a potemkin tour of what china wants uses
he wants the world to see
and therefore lacks credibility is that
a fair assessment
no you know we are we're loaded into
buses and we go to visit places but
we don't just wander around and take a
few pictures we
look into things we ask questions we say
why is this here
what happened then and we're talking to
the people who collected the samples
from the floor of the market
but then tested positive even more
important
is the data that chinese scientists have
been collecting over the last year
i mean they are sharing data with us
that we've not seen before that no one's
seen before
they are talking with us openly about
every possible pathway
so i think we're really getting some i
think any member of the team would say
that
tomorrow the experts will visit the
wuhan institute of virology
researchers there handled coronaviruses
but have rejected the possibility of a
leak
dr dashak has a long-standing working
relationship with the lab
but is not ruling the theory out you
know my relationship with
china my work here my my
um connections to the wohan institute of
virology and
xi jinglei are very well known and
they're really well known because i've
spent 20 years or 15 years
publishing the data and i think that's a
pretty
worthwhile thing that we've been doing
we're all aware of the hypotheses
around the potential the lab involvement
in this
and we're certainly going to ask
questions about um all of the key
aspects of the wuhan institute of
biology
and he's optimistic about eventually
finding the origins of covid19
but has a stark warning about the
situation now
well you know i'm i'm of the mindset
that this virus is going to be with us
forever this is one of the viruses that
jumped into humans
and then became endemic and will be with
us forever
did you find anything forever we'll
have to wait though right now they need
to find answers
tom cheshire sky news beijing